in the early 1990s two teams of
astronomers had set out to measure just
what the universe was made of
these two teams known as the high zed
supernova search team and the supernova
cosmology project brought together
astronomers from around the globe with
the goal of charting cosmic expansion
over the life of the universe
the astronomers expected the presence of
all the matter and radiation in the
universe to act like a drag on the
expansion steadily slowing it as the
cosmos aged by measuring this
deceleration all the matter and energy
that make up the universe would be
revealed
these international collaborations
cooled on the world's mightiest
telescopes such as the eight-meter keck
telescope in hawaii and orbiting hubble
space telescope to scour the sky
their target was supernovae acting as
beacons of the distant cosmos whose
brightness as measured through our
telescopes revealed how the universe had
expanded as their light traveled for
billions of years
but the astronomers
were in
for a shock
our universe
is not slowing down
it
is speeding up
after repeatedly searching for flaws in
their observations and checking their
calculations they presented their
conclusions to a startled world
and to account for this accelerated
expansion there was something else in
the universe
something unexpected driving the cosmos
faster and faster
and whilst there must be immense
quantities of this stuff for the effect
to take place it remained and remains
totally invisible to our telescopes
whatever is out there between the stars
and galaxies accelerating the expansion
it is truly
dark
this result netted the leaders of the
experiment brian schmidt saul perlmutter
and adam reese the 2011 nobel prize in
physics and this discovery of dark
energy came at the end of a tumultuous
century
astronomers had discovered that our sun
was an ordinary star in an ordinary
galaxy nowhere in particular in an
expanding universe
shocking was the revelation that in
terms of mata all the atoms in all the
stars in all the galaxies
a little more than cosmic
bit players
all the matter we can see appeared to be
dwarfed by huge quantities of unseen
matter revealed only by its
gravitational pull
and as 1998 dawned we realized that even
this dark matter was significantly
outweighed by the presence of the newly
discovered dark energy
two vast components of the cosmos
unseeable and for millennia
undetectable
it is currently the biggest question in
cosmology
what are these new components of our
universe
how
do they work
and where did they come from
[Music]
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
question out of the 100 billion planets
in the milky way how many could have the
potential ingredients for life 7
15 million 300 million
more than a billion that's right
excluding earth only about 300 million
including earth same answer and so my
recommendation for magellan's new
documentaries released this week is
other earths the search for habitable
planets an exclusive new documentary
that dives into the world of exoplanets
it's a great watch and really opened my
eyes to how many factors have to be just
right for life to exist let alone thrive
magellan tv are sort of netflix for
documentaries with more than 3 000
videos to choose from on a wide range of
topics and this christmas history of the
universe viewers can take advantage of a
special holiday offer buy one get one
free gift cards for an annual membership
by clicking on the link in the
description
thanks
on the 29th of may 1919 a total eclipse
of the sun passed over the southern
atlantic
two expeditions headed by british
astronomers arthur eddington and frank
dyson set off to observe this phenomenon
one team headed to brazil the other to
west africa
the expeditions were beset by problems
from faulty instruments to weather that
refused to cooperate
on the island of principe off the coast
of africa the eclipse was due at two in
the afternoon
but throughout the morning eddington had
sat in the pouring rain the sun not
peaking from behind the grey until half
an hour before the eclipse
clouds continued to cross the sky even
as it darkened eddington busied himself
changing photographic plates in the
telescope only glancing momentarily at
one of nature's most spectacular sights
would the observation be a lost cause
would all this effort be a waste of time
a few days later eddington had his
answer
[Music]
and our picture of the universe
changed
forever
the headline in the new york times
proclaimed lights or the skew in the
heavens and the little-known albert
einstein became the most famous
scientist in the world
four years earlier during the turbulent
years of the first world war einstein
had published his general theory of
relativity the culmination of a decade's
hard work relativity gave us a new
picture of gravity replacing newton's
forces with malleable space-time
during the war years relativity was an
academic curiosity but with peace
restored scientists had set out to test
the predictions of this new scientific
theory
their goal had been to measure the
locations of background stars whose
light passed close to the edge of the
sun stars that would be visible when the
immense glare of the sun was dimmed
during an eclipse
if einstein was correct the gravity of
the sun should act like a lens gently
deflecting the starlight from its
straight-line path
and on the photographic plates obtained
in brazil and africa the stars had
shifted by the predicted amount
einstein's theory
had triumphed
whilst the result made him a star
einstein thought that this gravitational
lensing had little practical consequence
stars were simply not massive enough to
use as natural telescopes to magnify the
distant universe
nothing could be there was nothing in
the universe with enough mass to have
such an effect
[Music]
or at least
as far
as he knew
in the 1930s astronomer fritz zviki was
working at the california institute of
technology
[Music]
zviki was a brilliant scientist with a
prickly personality combining geometry
and profanity he referred to his enemies
as spherical bastards implying they were
a bastard no matter which way you looked
at them
but as an original thinker zviki's mind
roamed through the mysteries of the
universe
he coined the word supernova to describe
immense stellar explosions and realized
a super dense remnant known as a neutron
star would be left in the ashes
and in 1933
fritz vicki was focusing on the coma
cluster located 300 million light years
away coma is immense and home to
thousands of individual galaxies
this was barely a decade after the
realization that the milky way was not
alone in the universe and numerous other
galaxies exist scattered throughout the
cosmos
zviki reasoned that the individual
galaxies in coma were held in their
orbits by the gravitational pull of all
the other galaxies around it
he realized that by measuring the
galactic speeds he could determine just
how much mass was in the coma cluster
providing a new way of weighing the
galaxies
but instead
what vicky found was a big problem
the galaxies in the coma cluster were
moving far too fast with only the
gravitational effect of the galaxies in
play each galaxy in coma should have
been travelling sedately in its orbit
with immense speeds of almost a thousand
kilometers per second
coma should have been tearing itself
apart
it was clear significantly more gravity
was needed to hold coma together
what was the source
of this extra gravity
with nothing obvious zviki concluded
that there must be
duncal materi
dark matter gravitationally binding the
coma cluster and there had to be a lot
more dark matter than the stars we can
see
zviki's realization that much of the
mass in the universe is dark
was startling
questions immediately sprung to mind
how much is there what is it made from
and how can we measure
zwicky's discovery should have set the
astronomy world on fire
but instead
there was silence
possibly because of his brusque style
this notion of dark matter lay buried in
the pages of scientific journals and for
the next few decades astronomers had a
new focus
measuring the expansion speed of the
universe
by the 1970s there were new
technological advances large telescopes
and sensitive instruments for observing
the heavens
and with these a new generation of
astronomers was asking new questions
about the universe
vera rubin the target was large spiral
galaxies similar to our own milky way
working with her collaborator kent forte
rubin wanted to understand how these
galaxies spin
[Music]
she had entered astronomy when it was
essentially a male-only activity and she
encountered resistance throughout her
career including a lack of female
bathrooms in the telescopes she used
but this didn't stop her as she
undertook meticulous observations of the
rotation speeds of spiral galaxies the
expectation was that these galaxies were
like the solar system with most of the
mass concentrated towards the center
just like the planets the speeds of
stars in the spiral disk were expected
to fall as gravity gets weaker towards
the edge
but this
was not what rubin found
the rotation speed of stars did not
diminish but remained roughly the same
all the way to the edge of the galaxies
just like vicki rubin was left with a
gravitational puzzle
what was the source of gravity needed to
keep the stars moving
at their unexpected speeds
zviki's dark matter was back in the
spotlight
it was becoming clear that what we could
see with our telescopes the myriads of
stars and clouds of gas
were nothing but minor cosmic players
astronomers were faced with a stark
question
is there an entire shadow universe of
dark matter out there
the evidence was growing
and it was now they turned to einstein's
seemingly inconsequential theoretical
prediction made more than half a century
before
they turned to gravitational lensing
indeed zviki had suspected this also
years before he had reasoned that with
the extra dark matter galaxies and
clusters of galaxies would be powerful
gravitational lenses
but it took until the 1960s for
scientists to really come to grips with
this concept and find a point of energy
staggeringly huge enough to properly
observe
quasars
appearing as little more than points of
light through the most powerful
telescopes
they shine with the brightness of more
than a hundred trillion stars
it was realized that quasars were
powered by supermassive black holes the
gravitational pull of these black holes
accelerates in falling material to close
to light speed as it swirls into the
inner regions mata crashes together
heating it to immense temperatures
and it is this accreting disk of matter
that glows so brightly
and with this immense brightness
astronomers could spot quasars at
incredible distances many billions of
light years from earth by the 1970s with
their observational approaches honed
finding quasars was routine
then in 1979 juan quasar
uninspiringly labeled
[Music]
q0957 plus 561
provided a puzzle
astronomers realized that this appeared
to be two quasars very close to each
other in the sky this is not too unusual
but it was found that these two quasars
appeared to be
identical
the astronomers realized that they were
seeing double a gravitational mirage
between us and the quasar sits a massive
galaxy and its gravity distorts our view
producing two separate images of the
single object
zviki was right again and more than 80
years since it was first observed under
the clear skies of africa and brazil
gravitational lensing had found its
purpose
in the decades that followed thousands
of gravitational lenses have been
discovered many of these are due to
individual galaxies but the most
spectacular are produced by the immense
gravity of gravity clusters
distant galaxies that would be too faint
to see in our telescopes are magnified
by these cluster lenses appearing as
immense arcs
every instance of gravitational lensing
provides an opportunity to measure how
much mass is present
by measuring the distortion
and the conclusion
is always
the same
there is a lot more mass
than that visible as stars and gas
in fact
most of the matter in our universe
is completely
dark
but it wasn't just gravitational lenses
that revealed the ubiquitous presence of
dark matter
everywhere astronomers looked dark
matter was needed to explain their
observations
from immense flows of galaxies through
the universe to the presence of gas in
galaxy clusters that had been
gravitationally squeezed by dark matter
dark matter was everywhere
and it dominated the gravitational pulls
of the cosmos
finally we came to realize
that it
had shaped
our universe
[Music]
looking up at the night sky the black
is filled with stars
some
form patterns
for millennia humanity has interpreted
shapes from these arrangements creating
meaning from their placement
from the ancient egyptians to the inca
these constellations have captured our
imaginations
but behind these simple patterns
lurk complex
incomprehensibly huge
clusters
many billions of light years away many
billions of light years across with many
billions of stars and galaxies within
them
the great wall
the giant ark
and indeed where we live
laniakea
and so it was in the 1970s that
astronomers started to chart the
locations of galaxies
they began to create an atlas
of the universe
the idea was simple a measurement of
cosmic speed due to the expansion of the
universe reveals a galaxy's distance
but this meant collecting and analyzing
the light from many individual galaxies
a laborious task dedicated programs were
established to measure galaxy light with
one of the first being the cfa redshift
survey based at harvard's university
center for astrophysics and as
measurements were gathered the structure
of the universe was revealed
it was clear galaxies were part of a
cosmic web with individual clusters
linked with filaments embedded in this
structure were huge empty regions known
as voids giving the universe a
sponge-like appearance
by the mid-1990s two astronomers john
hucra and margaret geller had analyzed
the light of eighteen thousand galaxies
they labeled immense structures such as
the great wall and the stickman each
composed of thousands
more modern surveys of galaxies
including the 2df galaxy redshift survey
and sloan digital skies survey have
mapped more than a million revealing
clusters filaments and voids throughout
the universe
but this raised the question
where did all this cosmic structure
come from
astronomers knew that the fiery birth of
the universe in the big bang left it
featureless the hydrogen and helium
forged in the first few minutes were
smoothly spread through the cosmos
but underlying this
was dark matter
4. in the time before the first stars
when the cosmos was truly dark
dark matter was starting to stir
in the beginning the matter in the
universe wasn't perfectly smooth
a burst of expansion known as inflation
in the earliest moments had written very
slight ripples in the universe
some places in the early universe were
slightly more dense than others other
places were less dense
and even though these density
differences were tiny they were enough
for gravity to do its work
and this gravity from very slight over
densities started pulling material
in
matter began to flow and hydrogen and
helium gas came along for the ride
after 100 million years densities grew
and gas pooled
chunks of hydrogen and helium fragmented
out of the clouds from this cooling and
collapsing gas the first stars were born
and in the universe again there was
light
forming in the dense knots of dark
matter these infant stars lit up the
sights of the first galaxies
over the billions of years that followed
dark matter drew in more mass with
growing quantities of dark matter
accompanied by more stars and gas
and so 14 billion years after the birth
of the universe
these fully formed galaxies sit at the
hearts of immense halos of dark matter
unravelling the process of galaxy
evolution is complex astronomers need to
understand the ebb and flow of gas the
life cycles of stars and the formation
of black holes
combining all this physics is difficult
so astronomers turn to supercomputers to
solve the highly coupled non-linear
equations
it is now routine for astronomers to
generate synthetic universes watching
the interplay of the numerous processes
that have shaped our cosmos
the resultant insights are astounding
and beautiful watching galaxies emerge
from the early cosmic fog
and quite clearly the dominant factor is
dark matter
providing the framework against which
galaxies can evolve
without it it would have been extremely
difficult for stars and galaxies to
begin to form
astronomers realized that dark matter
had to have some particular properties
to build cosmic structure as well as its
gravitational influence they realized
that mata must move relatively
sluggishly through the universe as too
much speed would make it disperse rather
than clump
they called it cold dark matter with the
cold referring to its slow speed
and so dark matter clearly played a huge
role in the development of complexity in
the universe
but one
huge question remained
just
what
is it
[Music]
in 1930 wolfgang poorley was faced with
a problem
radioactivity had been studied for
several decades but one kind of particle
decay was behaving strangely
this beta decay appeared to be
relatively simple with an atomic nucleus
spitting out an electron or its
antimatter cousin the positron but for a
collection of identical atomic nuclei
the particles that got spat out had
different properties some sped away at
high speed others moved more slowly this
meant that some had high energies whilst
others had lower energies
how could this be the conservation of
energy demanded that each of these
ejected particles should have the same
speed poorly wondered if the
conservation of energy was being broken
a distressing conclusion he couldn't
stomach
instead he suggested another thing is
also spat out during beta decay
another particle that carried away the
seemingly missing energy
named the neutrino this purely
hypothetical particle had some peculiar
properties the fact that it did not
collide with atoms told us it wasn't a
photon the particle of light
it was something else something
different
it wasn't until the 1950s that paulie's
hypothetical particle was finally
detected in sensitive experiments set up
next to nuclear reactors a prestigious
source of neutrinos
astronomers realized that the universe
was full of neutrinos most produced in
the frenetic nuclear reactions in the
earliest epoch of the universe
given that they barely interact with
mata it was suggested that these
neutrinos could be the dark matter
but as experiments improved it was
realized that neutrinos are just too
minuscule and too fast to account for
dark matter's gravitational dominance
physicists would have to continue the
search
what else could be dark enough to be
dark matter
what else
could be massive enough
one possibility was quickly ruled out
dark matter could not be made of atoms
it is possible to hide atomic matter
making it dark by cooling it so that it
doesn't emit any energy we could imagine
dark matter in the form of chilled
clouds of hydrogen between the stars but
the cooking of elements during the big
bang puts strong limits on how much
atomic matter there can be
and it's simply not enough to account
for all that is needed
another obvious candidate is black holes
these are clearly dark being the
ultimate trap for light and we will only
feel their presence through their
gravitational attraction
possibly these black holes were born in
cracks in space-time defects that
existed in the first moments of the big
bang
huge numbers of these primordial black
holes could course between the stars but
as einstein realized the gravitational
pull of each black hole would make it
behave like a gravitational lens
distorting and focusing light of the
more distant universe
as a black hole passes directly in front
of a more distant star the resulting
magnification would for a period of
around a month make the star appear
brighter
even if all dark matter were in the form
of black holes the chances of such a
passage is exceedingly small however in
the 1990s astronomers were searching for
these rare brightening events
but after more than a decade of hunting
for the gravitational microlensing the
result was disappointment
dark matter cannot be composed
of black holes
whilst astronomers were gazing skyward
particle physics were hunting for dark
matter in the world of the subatomic
through the course of the 20th century
they had unraveled the fundamental
nature of matter finding the particles
from which mass and forces are
constructed
comprised of quarks and leptons photons
and gluons as well as the more esoteric
w and z bosons this zoo of particles was
rounded off in 2012 with the discovery
of the higgs boson
this standard model of particle physics
has proved to be a great success
it accurately accounts for the tumult of
particles pouring out of the immense
collisions at the large hadron collider
and other particle physics experiments
despite this
we know
it must be
incomplete
missing from the standard model of
particle physics are at least two key
aspects of the universe
it can account for the strong and weak
nuclear forces and electromagnetism but
gravity is still resisting being added
to the quantum world
and also missing
is dark matter
nowhere in the possible particles is
there an obvious place for dark matter
to be hiding knowing the mathematics of
the standard model must be incomplete is
a potential gold mine for theoretical
physicists they can explore how the
mathematics can be unfolded and extended
and every new addition to the standard
model adds room for candidates for dark
matter but just like there are many
directions you can wander off from a
single point
there are many potential paths you can
take when extending mathematical ideas
one of the promising ideas was proposed
in the 1970s just as the mathematics of
the standard model was crystallizing the
key problem was the strong force the
force responsible for binding quarks
into protons and neutrons and gluing
protons and neutrons together in atomic
nuclei as originally derived the
mathematics allowed the strong force to
break a possible symmetry in the
universe something known as charge
parity violation
but all experiments appeared to show the
strong force was well behaved refusing
to break the symmetry
the mathematics needed an extension
known as the pache queen mechanism to
shore up the symmetry
and it was the presence of this
mechanism that implied the existence of
a new member of the zoo of fundamental
particles
nobel prize winner frank vilcek dubbed
this new particle the axion taking the
name from a popular washing detergent as
it cleaned up several problems in
physics
whilst these axions hypothetically
individually possess a tiny amount of
mass they would be extremely numerous
and would only interact with atomic
matter very rarely
it appeared to be an ideal dark matter
candidate
but to date not a single axion has been
detected in the uncountable number of
high energy collisions at the large
hadron collider
it remains
a contender
other approaches to extending the
standard model of particle physics have
yielded other possibilities for dark
matter supersymmetry doubles the
particle zoo as well as electrons and
quarks there are selectrons and squawks
there are also photinos we knows and
xenos
perhaps hidden within this larger family
is the sought after dark matter
different mathematical ideas have
sterile neutrinos massive cousins of
those that we know or possibly hooper
ons or cue balls or the latent higgs
field or asymmetric dark matter the
problem remains that physicists have a
shopping list of possible candidates but
as yet no experimental result suggests
that we are even on the right path to
understanding what dark matter is
finally in their quest some particle
physicists have joined with the
astronomers to look back to the heavens
several of the mathematical ideas for
dark matter suggest that it might
self-annihilate in the same way that an
electron and positron can collide and
transform into two photons and if it
does self-annihilate then perhaps we can
detect the high-energy radiation that
would be emitted
telescopes are currently trained on the
locations where we think dark matter
density would be the highest
and there is a potential signal an
unexpected glow of high energy gamma
rays from the galactic centre
it is still not clear whether these are
from mundane astrophysical sources or
possibly could reveal the discovery of
dark matter
and only time will tell
[Music]
though the question still lingered on at
the frontier of cosmology at the end of
the 1990s clear progress was being made
with many possibilities opening up the
composition of the universe was getting
a little less blurry
and then
as sometimes happens in physics
a result came along that totally upended
what had come before
we opened this story with the discovery
of the other dark component
dark energy in the closing years of the
20th century
as the shock of this discovery subsided
questions began to grow
just what was this new dark mysterious
stuff of the universe
whilst dark energy sat at the bleeding
edge of modern physics
it was realized that its story
was much older
and so
we return
to einstein
[Music]
with his general theory of relativity in
hand he wanted to deduce the equations
that govern the dynamics of the universe
but something
wasn't right
einstein felt that the universe was
static and unchanging the same now as it
had always been
his equations however presented a
different picture that the universe
should be a dynamic place changing and
evolving
perplexed by this he explored his
equations wondering if he'd missed
something
he realized that there was a term which
could act like an anti-gravity and as
there seemed to be little evidence for
anti-gravity he assumed it was zero
but
he still wondered
what if it wasn't
[Music]
through this he found a remarkable
effect that he could get this
anti-gravity to counter the dynamic
nature of his equations and make his
model universe static
and after introducing this cosmological
constant and being pleased with himself
he told the world
but not all the world agreed
especially the russian physicist
alexander friedman he held no favoritism
for a static and unchanging universe
pointing out to einstein that the notion
of a dynamic and expanding universe is
much more likely
initially einstein objected to
friedman's conclusion but eventually was
convinced and so he threw this
cosmological constant into the
scientific waste bin
he later supposedly called it his
biggest blunder
and this dismissal meant that no one
considered the notion of a cosmological
constant for many decades
and whilst these theorists were
grappling with the mathematics of an
expanding universe astronomers were
charting the heavens at the mount wilson
observatory edwin hubble was using the
world's largest telescope the 100 inch
hooker to measure the distance to
galaxies hubble's goal was to identify
particular stars known as cepheids as he
could calculate their true brightness
these standard candles revealed the
distance to their host galaxies
hubble combined his galactic distances
with galactic speeds measured with
doppler shift and found something quite
peculiar the more distant the galaxy the
faster it was moving
and other than the closest galaxies
all were moving away
whilst he didn't realize it hubble had
discovered conclusive proof
the universe
was expanding
and over the remainder of the 20th
century astronomers have refined
hubble's observations
huge observing programs were organized
to chart the universe measuring the
distances and velocities of many
thousands of galaxies
the goal was a single number known as
hubble's constant which was a measure of
the rate of universal expansion
and this brings us back to the very
beginning of our story
modern surveys of the heavens with
supernovae acting as standard candles
finally revealed that this universal
expansion
is
accelerating
and so again we are left to ask the
question
what is the dark element of the cosmos
causing
this effect
to begin with it cannot be mata or
radiation as these slow down expansion
to speed up expansion something else is
needed something that seems like an
anti-gravity
astronomers called this mysterious stuff
dark energy
but in reality einstein's cosmological
constant
was back
the existence of dark energy was not the
only surprise
when the cosmic accounting was completed
astronomers realized that all the atomic
matter the stars the planets the immense
gas clouds and galaxies comprised less
than five percent of the universe
dark matter the scaffolding of the
cosmos is about 25
dark energy made up the remainder
70
of the universe
many physicists were baffled
why is the universe completely dominated
by this mystery stuff
and in the two decades since its
discovery the evidence for the existence
of dark energy has become overwhelming
its presence is written into the
distributions of galaxies spread over
billions of light years it is also
written into the cosmic microwave
background the radiation left over from
the fiery start of the universe
and it has seemingly bizarre properties
as the universe expands matter and
radiation thin out
dark energy however appears to remain
constant
this means that in the early universe
matter and radiation dominated and the
presence of dark energy had no impact
but about five billion years ago the
tables were turned
mata had thinned out to the point where
dark energy became dominant and the
acceleration of cosmic expansion began
in earnest
this accelerated expansion dilutes mata
even faster meaning the future universe
will be completely dominated by dark
energy
in about 100 billion years this
expansion will have carried all galaxies
outside of our local group beyond our
cosmic horizon
eventually
the universe will again
return
to darkness
[Music]
in quantum mechanics empty space is not
truly
empty
heisenberg's uncertainty principle
allows energy to fluctuate in and out of
existence on tiny scales
this quantum nature of the vacuum
provides empty space with a tension
attention that can be measured in
experiments
and whilst our cosmological equations
offer few clues to the nature of dark
energy it can tell us something
unlike normal gas that possesses an
outward pushing pressure
dark energy has a tension
that pulls
and there is one thing in nature that
possesses this similar tension
the quantum
vacuum
but problems begin when physicists try
to calculate just how much energy there
is in such a fluctuating vacuum as their
answer is simply ridiculous
the mismatch between their mathematics
and the amount of energy observed in
dark energy differ by an immense factor
of 10 to the power of 120.
some have called this the worst
prediction in all the physics but it
signals that if the vacuum is
responsible for dark energy
we have a lot to learn about its true
properties
and that is just one suggestion
indeed with so little in terms of
observational evidence proposing ideas
for the nature of dark energy has become
a theoretical playground
[Music]
various fields have been proposed some
aloof sitting in the background of the
universe and doing their own thing
others have wondered whether dark energy
is related to the other bout of
accelerated expansion in the life of our
universe
the epoch of inflation is thought to
have taken place when the universe was
about 10 to the minus 35 seconds old the
driving force behind inflation was
another mysterious and hypothetical
field the inflaton
could dark energy be a resurgence of the
inflaton
the best we can say
is maybe
of course there is one other invisible
element controlling the cosmos
so the question
has been asked
are dark energy
and dark matter related
again physicists can derive mathematical
models where there are interactions in
the dark sector where dark matter and
dark energy possess a common origin in
fact the dark sector could potentially
host its own physics as rich as those in
the atomic world
but with the limited observational
evidence
we are again stuck in the world of
theory
clearly more observations and
measurements are required a whole host
of experiments are underway with many
more planned for the immense telescopes
that are currently making their way from
drawing board to reality in chile the
8.4 meter telescope at the vera rubin
observatory will turn its eye to the sky
in 2022 the 40-meter european extremely
large telescope also in chile will have
its first light in 2024
the key goals of these and other
telescopes is to uncover the mysteries
of dark matter and dark energy this
includes searching for the signs that
dark energy might not be exactly
einstein's cosmological constant perhaps
dark energy has evolved and changed over
the billions of years of the universe
maybe it has decayed into mata and
radiation these would provide new clues
to the true nature of dark energy and
open new avenues of research to unravel
its physics
however as of today all observations
suggest that dark energy appears to be
precisely einstein's cosmological
constant
unchanging over the life of the universe
but this sends a shiver down the spine
of cosmologists as it might mean that
the cosmological constant is uncrackable
just a part of the universe a
fundamental property of space
without an origin to understand
going even further for some failure to
fathom the nature of dark matter and
dark energy represents a failure of the
fundamental laws of physics
they argue instead of hunting the
heavens and particle accelerators for
physical substances perhaps we should
look closely at our cherished theories
for example what if gravity is only
approximated by einstein's theory of
relativity and the truth has yet to be
discovered this could mean that gravity
behaves strangely on large scales not
simply getting weaker
this too could account for the rotation
curves of galaxies the gravitational
lensing of light and the accelerated
expansion without the need of a physical
dark matter or dark energy
but as yet all contenders have failed to
match the success of einstein's
mathematics in explaining the universe
the search
continues
and so today our universe is completely
dominated by its dark side
and in truth
it remains
mysterious
if dark matter and dark energy are
physical things we need to determine
their true properties to understand
their place in the universe
without these questions like where they
arose in cosmic history and how they
impact the fundamental nature of the
cosmos will remain difficult
if not impossible to answer
but if the dark side is only a mirage
due to the limits of our physical
theories then an even bigger upheaval to
our understanding is on the cards
until then the dark side of the universe
holds the keys
and it is holding them tightly
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like and
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
[Music]